son 37 pero se agrupan en siete cargos
federales contra el expresidente Donald
Trump le doy le voy a dar cuatro que son
los más importantes los que más tendrían
efecto legal en contra de el
expresidente el primero es la retención
deliberada información de defensa
nacional el segundo es el ocultamiento
corrupto de documentos clasificados El
tercero es conspirar para obstruir a la
justicia esto En el caso de las trabas
que puso el expresidente para no
entregar la información cuando se le
pidió fue casi un proceso de un año que
archivos federales le pidió al
presidente que entregara esta
información y el expresidente
simplemente no la entregó y el cuarto
que es declaraciones falsas el
presidente negó haber tenido esta
información después dijo que sí la tenía
pero que no la había manejado mal
entonces
37 cargos que se resumen en siete y
estos cuatro los más relevantes y Pues
los medios nacionales están resaltando
que en esta información que manejó mal y
que no quiso entregar Pues hay evidencia
evidencia que el expresidente Donald
Trump habría compartido información
delicada de defensa en cuanto a un
ataque un ataque militar planeado por el
Departamento de defensa que este plan
este plan militar lo había compartido
con escritores y con otras personas que
no tenían el circuito es decir que no
tenían la la potestad ni tenían la
legalidad de saber esta información
confidencial
está viviendo una jornada bastante
movida no Además dos de sus abogados
Defensores como decíamos previamente
renunciaron al caso que podría implicar
esto de Cara a la comparecencia que está
prevista para el próximo martes en una
corte de Miami
estos dos abogados son
y John Roly y en un comunicado porque no
quisieron hablar con la prensa
directamente dijeron que lo hacían
porque el caso pasaba a Miami no
quisieron dar mayores explicaciones de
por qué salieron simplemente salen según
ellos en buenos términos el expresidente
Donald Trump en su red social también
les agradeció por todo el trabajo que
han que habían hecho los dos sin embargo
tanto los abogados salientes como el
expresidente Donald Trump en su red
social dicen que lo que hay es una
justicia política politizada que los
demócratas quieren aprovechar de Cara a
la campaña ahora entonces y lo anunció
también el expresidente su abogado será
Total que también lo representa en los
acasos que lleva el expresidente en
Nueva York no quiso el expresidente
mencionar Que firma de abogado es la que
estaría representando Y pues obviamente
salió con ataques a sus contrincantes
políticos tratando también de politizar
este este ataque este revés que está
sufriendo el ex presidente Donald Trump
para su campaña de reelección